President Biden visited Selma Alabama
yesterday on the anniversary of the
Civil Rights march known as Bloody
Sunday civil rights leaders joined the
president marching across the Edmund
Pettus bridge where police and state
troopers attacked voting rights
demonstrators 58 years ago Mr Biden
called for new government action to
protect the right to vote
right to vote to have your vote counted
as the threshold of democracy and
Liberty
with it anything's possible without it
without that right nothing is possible
and this fundamental the president
pointed to a Supreme Court case from
Alabama that could weaken the Voting
Rights Act that decision is expected by
the end of June